et nous sommes en ligne avec nathalie à
doute nick bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous vous trouvez actuellement
à tcherkassy une villa à 200 km environ
au sud de kiev mais vous êtes professeur
de français à kiev vous avez donc décidé
de fuir la capitale c'est cela oui c'est
ça bonjour et à cause que je dois que
pour vivre telle situation la deuxième
fois donc je suis originaire de deux
nièces et il y a huit ans
que je devais sans finir la première
fois et je ne pouvais rien faire
en étant sur le territoire de donetsk on
a essayé de faire quelque chose mais là
bas je devais laisser mes parents et
toute ma famille est maintenant c'est la
deuxième fois comme le déjà vu que je
dois
quitter oui et
abandonner ma maison ah bon c'est
vraiment terrible et
je ne sais pas
comment vous avez sûrement libre vous
avez fui kiev quand exactement
à acheter
et au jour de début de la guerre c'était
leader du matin qu'on a qu'on a compris
qu'il ya des attaques de bombes on a
entendu une alerte
dans les rues
et on a essayé de partir par quels
moyens êtes vous parti de la capitale
direction tcherkassy en train
n'ont qu'un bon accule en voiture vous
vous trouvez donc à tcherkassy je le
disais où êtes vous actuellement et dans
quel état d'esprit êtes vous vous nous
le disent et c'est la deuxième fois que
vous devez quitter votre ville d'auch
nièce qui vit à 8 ans et est maintenant
kiev on imagine que c'est
émotionnellement évidemment terrible
oui bon
[Musique]
comment est on arrivé à
kiev juste centre coeur de pierre on a
compris que c'est non loin de me lancer
non loin le fils du président
sur le même étage
j'ai compris que c'était maintenant très
dangereux et il y à des bâtiments où il
n'ya pas de cave où il n'ya pas de refus
il n'ya pas d'abri aux où se cacher mon
jeu on a on a pris la décision de partir
et vous vivez vous actuellement vous
avez de la famille tcherkassy comment
organisez-vous votre vie
c'est la maison des parents de mon mari
bon air
ici
on a décidé de
participer
aux bénévoles
notre part avec des gens qui est récolte
les aliments pour je suis pas pour aider
les soldats pour révéler les jeunes
hommes qui est et qui défend maintenant
notre pays voilà et qui serait bien
utile
quelle est l'atmosphère là où vous vous
trouvez est ce que les ukrainiens
panique est ce que tout le monde se
mobiliser et
essaie d'aider à leur manière les
soldats d'ukrainiens au oui de monclin
ganila les gens
se regroupent et son ensemble voilà il
n'y a pas de panique maintenant mais si
c'est plus demeure calme
malgré les plus dures alerte donc ça
peut être senti à l'aise à prendre dans
la journée ça peut être la leur ca à
deux heures du matin à 1h du matin donc
presque chaque de trois heures il y à
des alertes mais en tout cas les gens
les gens sont plus de montcalm on est
dans l'autre donc des coups de main
voilà et et au niveau de
l'approvisionnement en nourriture est ce
que vous manquez de quelque chose ou
pour l'instant la situation est
relativement normale
entre les deux mois normal comme c'est
un petit village et ya plein de gens qui
ont des maisons privées et qui ont des
potagers ou bien des commandes et
les animaux de faire quelque chose comme
ça il n'y a pas de bons manque de
provisions et il ya des gens qui ont par
exemple des cochons quelque chose et il
récolte des aliments pour envoyer pour
les remet à la frontière pour les
soldats voilà pour l'instant vous restez
à hatcher cas si vous n'avez pas
d'intention de partir et éventuellement
de de partir dans un autre pays
non non pas du tout et ont été
recoupées avec notre famille avec avec
les parents de mon mari
et qui on était deux ont comme on n'a
pas d'enfant
on a décidé de participer à bénévolat
voilà eaux et des eaux gens et d'être
utile
merci merci beaucoup nathalie à 12 nique
pour votre témoignage merci